good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy tuesday that
really feels like a monday because it's
the first episode of the morning shows
this week and we have got my favorite
co-host the only co-host who truly
matters she's not like other co-hosts
it's jackie oh also known as haroldson's
mom hi harold's mom me yeah
hi i'm so excited to be back in studio
with you doing our thang and we are
twins today from top to bottom no we are
twins from way back like these outfits
are
sympatico
erotico hypnotico 100 we're both wearing
leggings sweatshirts and air force ones
but we're also wearing like sweatshirts
we've never worn before yeah i got this
sweatshirt um on tour someone gave it to
me and a lot of people think it's new
merch and i just have to say it's not
i'm really sorry and these girls came
from cleveland to um
was it chicago noah's in chicago and it
says today is a cleveland day and they
got you one too and i brought it for you
oh my gosh i have actually a whole bag
full of things for you okay oh my god
what's that bag don't ask
first up
today is a cleveland day crew neck from
your toasters in cleveland could have
really been twinning but then people
would have thought it was merch thought
it was a new march then i have seth then
i have a matching onesie for haraldson
i'm obsessed there you go oh my god he's
gonna love that i also have another
onesie for haroldson that says p-jump
p-jump alert p john
who him yes wait there's there's more
oh this one is my favorite says my
auntie is not like other girls oh my god
the toasters really showed up and showed
out for you they really did we should
put this person in charge of our merch
no no it's all for it's a bunch of
different people like it's not just one
oh okay because i was like and this is
probably the best one bryce's bro
i thought it said bryce's bra
um but it's so cute
it says bryce's bra it says bryce's
birthday he could be bryce's bra and
then we got a blue one that says aunt
claudia i'm flat broke oh my god you
don't understand like i feel like you
really need these i don't realize babies
actually wear these every day render all
of their cute outfits and i do need
these and he's going to be wearing these
every day and they're going to spark so
much joy for me thank you so much
there's one more item that is a personal
favorite of mine i have to shout out
these toasters from kansas city who went
to tj maxx and they bought you your
first piece
of ray dunn home and it is a mug that
says number one mom you guys i'm
obsessed i know first of all i got one
too the only one that says sunday fun
day this is a nice sized mug huge you
love to see a big mug and we pride
ourselves at the toast we do a big mug
we sell good mugs yeah we sell good mugs
i see the allure and also like who
doesn't want something that says number
one 100 you worked so hard to be a mom
and i was like to just be number one
it's a beautiful thing so much better
than number two
so much better so those are all the
gifts i transported across country for
you thank you so much they are all well
worth it they will all be getting used
this mug will be a while because i'm not
drinking coffee yet because like who
needs to be jittery when you're up all
the [ __ ] time so true um
these thank you guys so much i
absolutely love and adore yes so cute
right there's nothing better than giving
a gift to someone and like them loving
it and using it yeah
yeah it's like not like that puzzle that
i got you yeah no but actually it was
ben's 30th birthday and i got him a ps5
and like i'm very much looking forward
to him using it all the time that's a
great gift very difficult to track down
stockx i overpaid major league oh for
sure what's this little book stand you
have going on so many changes so many
changes at the studio so you know i used
to have this book just sitting here and
like propped up and you know how many
times i've knocked it over like it's so
annoying so we ordered this gorgeous
acrylic book stand and now it has the
book standing up you're really just like
getting everything in order moving on up
here yeah no ever since you've been gone
you know me i'd love to clean i'd love
to organize i loved it the studio does
look really good like the kitchen
net yep the counter where we keep snacks
is clean jackie calls me the sweeper
because like every now and then i'll get
in these moods where i just like need to
sweep up the place and i've been
sweeping non-stop ever since you've been
gone no it looks really good you can
tell and i feel like you're having you
like the sweeper news coming out since
i'm not here to like shame me yeah yeah
shame for my sweetheart she goes into
sweeping mode and like everything all of
a sudden is in the garbage even if you
were literally eating it at that current
moment yeah 100 but it's good yeah it
looks great here it looks great in here
um how's haroldson asking about his
auntie obviously he's so good he's so
busy he's always asking about his auntie
um hopefully he'll come by yeah i would
love to yeah he misses you a lot he
really does love your energy which is a
surprise you know because it's it could
go either way no actually your energy
could be polarizing it can but it can
only be polarizing to people who are
like fully conscious um and i think that
like my really um like annoying voice i
love to sing i actually think i'm the
perfect personality for a child yeah um
so that doesn't shock me at all actually
yeah no but i also feel like some
children could get like unski and cry
and like let you know they're not here
for it but he really is here for like
all of your
songs the wraps in the treetops all day
long happening popping into singing that
song all the little birdies on harry
street love to hear the harry go and
tweet tweet tweet little hairy
dilly day little harry
diddly day oh little harry cause you're
really gonna rock tonight little harry
little harry
that's the one that's that's the number
one most requested it's just crazy how
like you know i have really have a song
for every child yeah like taylor's was
me it was like kind of like a
a bohemian rhapsody moment miss
kind of a bohemian rhapsody similar
heavily inspired definitely well you're
doing well missing auntie he's doing
well how are you how are the brass how's
everything everything is good you know
everything is
chugging along yes swell swole
[Laughter]
everything is quite swolled good good
good um we've got an amazing show for
you guys we do have so much to talk
about i guess i was the last person on
the show yes so that's a good feeling to
not feel like i have to talk about
stories that you already covered um
so i'm excited to talk about all the
news from the long weekend that we had
how was your weekend in chicago and
kansas city it was incredible i'm
literally broken like beyond broken when
my alarm went off today i'm like there's
no way that it's alarm time it's four in
the morning um but it was incredible
like the chicago theater was definitely
a bucket list moment for me i wish you
were there it was like the best night of
my life literally lauren was there so i
got to see all the girlies peter
croussley came like it was kind of a
star-studded affair um the show was
amazing i can't lie i was
unbelievable like i was really so
talented so funny so unique so
charismatic um
and then i also went to kansas city
which really holds a special place in my
heart the kansas city toasters like
are fierce these gifts are they
predominantly both it's equal it's equal
otherwise i would have had a favorite
yeah i know but like you have to go to
kansas city jackie it's what you think
cleveland is okay it is for me like i
need a new sweatshirt that says it's a
kansas city day i was like landed and i
was on zillow like that's that's when
you know it's good it's a gorgeous town
so like so quiet but still like you know
lively great bars great restaurants
great people jackson mahomes it's great
what about austin no he wasn't there oh
well how great could it be then
and that was really like the end of the
tour i have one more show obviously
madison square garden tickets available
at
you will be seeing the show for the
first time which is so crazy i know
because last time you saw it like maybe
50 times
yeah yeah
i could recite it backwards and forwards
which i do all the time uh so i'm so
excited to get to experience it just
like as a true fan which i am yeah so
i'm so excited and also like by then i'm
excited to be like out and it's just
gonna be like a great night no i know
like you're gonna have you should get
your glam done i know yeah i've been
like dreaming of getting my makeup done
you should do it i'm going to but i
don't like know any makeup but you're a
makeup artist i've got a ton for you
yeah yeah you should i feel like that's
really what you need like it'll make you
feel so yeah like you have to get like a
new outfit you look stunning today thank
you we both do in our matching outfits
we're just like so beautiful so um
today is tuesday and we usually do
unburden yourselves on monday but i
really wanted to
do it today obviously because it's a
great segment but also i did a meet and
greet in chicago at foxtrot for those
who don't know spritz is now available
at foxtrots in chicago and this girl was
like i rode into unburdened ourselves
and you haven't read it yet i'm like oh
i'm so sorry and she told me what it was
and it was so psychotic that
we had to bring it on bring the segment
on on a tuesday it was the craziest
thing i've ever heard in my life can't
wait yeah you guys must unburden
yourselves even though it's not monday
like there's still burdens to be
unburdened so true so true and i think
we should jump right in because we have
so many stories that like we just need
to talk about
and without further ado it is time for
the fast five stories that you need to
know before you wake up and take a bite
out of your morning toast
and today's episode is brought to you by
thrive cosmetics high performance beauty
and skin care products that are made
with clean skin loving ingredients the
name causes in the name for the reason
every purchase supports organizations
that help women thrive so they have a
ton of fabulous products um their eye
products are some of my favorites
especially the mascara it's called the
liquid lash extensions mascara i've had
it since before they were a sponsor
because i saw like videos on facebook
and i was like oh my god i have the
worst lashes i cinched them off in a
fire pit in utah once and it just has
never been the same it's their best
selling product it has more than twenty
thousand five star reviews you'll get
ultra lengthening eye opening lashes
that last all day without clumping
smudging or flaking and it mimics the
look of a lash extension without
damaging glue or expensive salon prices
super easy to remove also
their formula slides right off with warm
water and a washcloth there's no soap
required they also have amazing skin
care products like their overnight
sensation brightening sleep mask which
is a potent skin loving formula that
restores hydrates and rejuvenates your
skin overnight the antioxidant packed
spa-inspired overnight mask for smoother
brighter more hydrated skin with this
cooling and brightening face mask
radiant skin is just a nice sleep away
everything from thrive cosmetics is
really good obviously my foray into the
brand was with their mascara but now i
just trust them wholeheartedly their
skin care is really good as well and
it's also just great to spend money on
makeup which a lot of us do but knowing
that that makeup is going to go back and
help you know causes that help women
thrive i think there's nothing better
than that and now is a great time
to try thrive cosmetics um for yourself
so their bigger than beauty promise is
for every product purchase thrive
cosmetics will donate to help women
thrive so that's women emerging from
homelessness surviving domestic abuse
fighting cancer and more so you can feel
good knowing that you're helping a great
company and right now you can get 15 off
your first order when you visit
thrivecosmetics.com
toast
that's thrive cosmetics and cosmetics is
spelled c a u s e
m e t i c s dot com slash toast for 15
off your first order and today's episode
is also brought to you by pros most of
you have probably heard of singing the
praises of prose the world's most
personalized hair care and for those who
haven't we wanted to tell you about the
incredible results we're seeing using
our customized prose products so pros
knows that there's more than just one
hair type and pros has given over a
million consultations with their
in-depth hair quiz which is how we got
started so there's no reason we all have
different hair texture hair types hair
problems there's no reason we should all
be using the same exact shampoo and
conditioner um and so for me i'm like
very conscious of damage because i have
really thick hair i blow dry or curl it
almost every day so that's a major
concern of mine but if you have you know
dry hair you have breakage whatever your
issue is their in-depth quiz will help
you find the exact customized hair
product for you so you can you know no
do your hair knowing that like process
your back
they also have a review and refine
feature which lets you tweak your
formula for any reason like if you want
to change your address or you have
different hair color different diet that
you're on there's a ton of things that
go into your hair care and process got
you covered from start to finish if
you're not 100 positive pros is the best
hair care you've had they will take the
products back no questions asked pros is
a healthy hair regimen with your name
all over it take your free in-depth hair
consultation and get 15 off your first
order today go to pros.com toast that's
p-r-o-s-e
dot com toast for your free in-depth
hair consultation and 15
off so i really like that you can
customize like the fragrance the smell
exactly what's in your formula and if
you're a customizable girly
check out pros we are customizable
girlies we are
the customized girlies yes okay before
we get into the stories i just uh wanted
to mention there was a shooting this
morning on the subway in new york city
and like an explosion and then more
undetonated bombs were found or what
looked to be like bombs right now 13
people are injured one person's in
critical condition but it's developing
and it's just like incredibly saddened
to make them it's so scary yeah in
brooklyn yeah so
agreed i hope everyone's okay and just
be careful like
everyone takes a subway it's so scary
it's so scary and incredibly sad but
we'll keep you posted
um first story little mindlessness love
mindlessness jlo and ben affleck are
engaged again
she announced v her via her on the jlo
newsletter okay let's talk about she and
ben are engaged so let's talk about two
things first of all let's talk about
them getting married this is the second
time they're engaged and then the
announcement yeah because those two
different things i have so much to say
on the latter but the first is this is
cute very happy for them i don't really
care i'm not like obsessed with this
story maybe it's because when they were
engaged the first time like i was so
young i wasn't like my pop culture maven
that i am now right so i really honestly
don't care i do love like the seven
husbands of jennifer lopez like i love
that for her i really do
i think they're cute the ring is pretty
happy for them here's the thing i think
the reason why we don't care has to do
with the announcement because i think if
there were like iconic photos or like
videos going around and everyone was
like posting them then we would be like
duped into caring yes with like instead
i really cared about them the whole time
like since they've reconnected no their
reconnection i agree like i was too
young to appreciate it um their
reconnection like really is shocking the
fact that they were engaging now they're
engaged again like is really [ __ ]
crazy yeah and i feel like when any time
we've gotten iconic photos from them
like everyone posts them and like you
see you see something a million times
like you you think that you care but
because there's no photos that are just
like or even of the ring it's just we
have like blurry videos no him on her
his knee there's nothing there's nothing
so because everyone not everyone is like
sharing the same thing over and over
again it's like oh does anyone care no
it's like a mysterious engagement like
there's no assets there be the lack of
assets i think
is to the situation but what's even more
germane is the thirst coming from jlo i
mean i guess
okay so she basically put a video on her
instagram and was like i have a really
big announcement
head over to my fan page on the jlo.com
which is like her website for her fan
club yeah and on the website there was
like this video basically saying she was
engaged and i just feel like you know
this is really something like i would do
like you know patreon i have a big
announcement
and the fact that jayla's doing it
definitely makes me feel better about my
current situation but also it's like a
hella tacky i'm like so confused beyond
and this is a woman with means like she
doesn't need she's a patron no she
doesn't so i'm so confused i mean unless
like you know her next big foray is into
the newsletter service right and she
wants to
start get as many clicks and subscribers
but this is really that's the most
shocking part not that benifer are
engaged again but she's announcing via
her website like it's like it's giving
reality star someone that i follow i
forget who because i wish i could credit
them said it's giving joju dice like
yeah like big shocking things go to the
link in my bio to watch literally okay
so i found out via a people magazine
notification i'm like oh my god so cute
ran to jlo's instagram and i see this
like twisted video
of her on the jlo.com and i was like
what the [ __ ] is this like what is going
on
i was never in my life have i been more
confused yeah me too i saw that you
posted that they were engaged so i went
to her page and it was a blurry video
it's like i guess she hasn't shared yet
right and i guess it was a pr like
publicist announcement and even still
like i have yet to see a photo of them
like together ring the ring is green
yeah or is it just the blurry video
right is it like a reflection i don't
know there's so little that we know
and they have been like so public this
whole time it's such a weird
announcement it is it's really weird but
let's talk about them being engaged
again and what's funny is like people
magazine is saying like they didn't want
to rush the engagement because they want
to make it work like
i feel like they just got back together
yeah this isn't not russia it's not
right it's like a year right no i think
it's less no yeah
yeah but that's crazy i mean
i like love that this is jayla's thing
like she just pops from engagement to
engagement she collects these like
stunning enormous rings from these
wealthy men
love that for her um i don't know if
this is going to be the one you know i
hope that it is i always hope that it is
yeah for everyone yeah of course
um
so i don't know like i don't know the
truth but i think it's cute i
i'm reticent to be excited because i was
burned by a-rod
oh my god i'm not alone
um so i was like really on board my ship
for her and a-rod i thought they were
the perfect couple um
and then they turned out to be quite the
opposite so i don't i just want to get
excited yeah but i do think that if
she's going like
you know it takes a lot to
get back with someone who really
publicly rejected you so i think that
like the fact that they're all in again
it has to be
real i mean
yes but
i don't know
i could see this not working out for
sure
i guess anything could happen right
because i thought in no way shape or
form or her and a-rod ever gonna break
up like i thought they were the perfect
couple i couldn't have picked two people
more perfect for each other and then
like not only did they not work out it
was like the most chaotic disgusting
mess like he really embarrassed her he
was like
acting a fool like i never thought so i
don't know what to think when it comes
to jlo honestly and part of me wants us
to not be her last engagement because
i'd love this for her you know yeah did
you watch watch what happens live last
night no no i did maya and lala can't
and i just have to say it was such a
good episode the two of them were so
classy maya from summerhouse maya from
summerhouse and it was it was just so
good i can't even tell you plus they're
both bravo fans they were just talking
about like all bravo shows and andy
asked lala like you know you're on watch
what happens i have a lot of people
watch like do you want to manifest like
you know going out with anyone like when
jayla was here she was talking about
a-rod and of course that didn't work out
but it's crazy that their relationship
started and ended on bravo totally yeah
and lala had such a good answer like i
would say you andy but you're not into
this oh my god did you see andy cohen's
instagram stories from like two nights
ago he was in the back of a car and he
was like i was just standing on sixth
avenue could not find a cab i'm so late
and like two bravo fans like picked him
up it was like a married couple the girl
in the front seat was
so pregnant her husband was in the other
the drive the driver's seat and he was
in the back and they were take taking
him uptown and it was so funny now i
want to get a car and like per ruth the
west village like looking for andy that
is really funny and he's never got to
take another cab again no but now he
can't do it again because now he knows
people like you are coming yeah who are
like looking for a show
and looking for a job we're gonna pitch
him yeah the whole way hey andy i've got
this great morning show for you i mean
bravo really does need a morning show
but yeah even though morning shows are
like flailing left right and center the
real this one not this one not yet the
morning the reel has been canceled but
that's an afternoon show is it i think
it's day time yeah morning for us
morning for us right it depends who you
are um and then another show shots of
sunset was also cancelled yeah that is a
huge blow for people like me like i'm
i'm devastated i don't understand why it
was canceled though like is it the
ratings is it the cast not wanting to do
it anymore first of all the cast is
obsessed with the show and there's so
much offline drama i mean mike shoehead
was arrested for domestic violence
literally last week so there's stuff
going on um
i don't know i don't know what the
reason was i do believe they have pretty
strong ratings yeah um so i was really
really shocked by this i'm so upset like
i could talk about my love for shaw's of
sunset your cans look sick i just love
that show more than life
you look like piece of wood like so good
um and i'm devastated that was really
one of my favorite shows of all time
i'm sorry and you know what i'm glad
that we you know on this show got to
interview reza mj like the two favorites
we had gigi on i'm glad that like i got
my pound of flesh we had um sherman
chervin swerving shervin we did like we
did good
but i'm
heartbroken like it's so good i'm sorry
and i never got to have um
destiny on like so many people like
just know and the shadows of sunset
fandom is small but mighty and just know
i stand with you
thank you that's beautiful claudia thank
you claudia that's beautiful so back to
jayla and ben overall thoughts
weird announcement i think it takes away
from the engagement the specialness yeah
but maybe they wanted it to be low-key
and get subscribers for the newsletter
right okay can we go to on the jlo yeah
i'm like what is really what i actually
have never even been there
oh okay
that's it it's extremely promotional it
looks like a like a like a real
newsletter oh i thought that was like a
404 page not found no no oh it's like a
subway okay so i put my email in well
you're about to sign up if you put your
email yeah accept sign up welcome to my
inner circle you're all signed up an
email has been sent to block check your
email for regular updates so does that
mean i don't get the update now oh so
it's just a newsletter yeah and you'll
get access to new special experiences
exclusive content and more okay so i
gotta unsubscribe sorry like i didn't
realize i thought i would get put my
email in and get like a whole website no
so it's not patreon it's not patreon
it's like sub stack
damn it's like sub stack yeah
okay i gotta unsubscribe i'll do that
later
anyways um sorry we just have some
breaking news um
kim kardashian and pete davidson um went
on a double date with jeff bezos and
lauren sanchez
okay so we're gonna skip to the next
story which is everything kardashian
we're putting them all in one story
it's not reasonable i'm sorry because
they're doing the most press they've
ever done in their lives they're giving
us all of these juicy tidbits everyone
is more relevant than ever like i we
could literally have chosen ten
kardashian stories today
women on the planet most interesting to
look at sure let's start with the
premiere which was thursday night the
premiere of the kardashians everyone
showed up and showed out except for
kendall and arguably maybe not kylie
yeah kylie like was photographed well
after everyone else was a lot of people
thought like maybe she had like a step
and repeat in her living room because
she wasn't photographed with anyone like
the family photo was chris courtney um
chloe and kim yeah and like no one she
wasn't in any getty images she's not in
the background of anything uh so people
think like she either
faked going or she like took all her
separate photos so that she could do
whatever she wanted but she was there
yeah i don't know why kendall wasn't
there i just kendall's sick oh okay
there's just been like a lot of press
kylie's been missing she wasn't on
kimmel right but then they did do this
big access hollywood thing which i
thought was like the best interview that
i've seen um
where was the interviewer i i think it
the the person was behind the stage yeah
but i mean behind the camera but i think
it was kit hoover who when we were on
access hollywood is the nicest woman
ever i think it was her okay um and i
believe her daughters are toasters i
just want to put that out there um but
she was asking the pertinent questions
to the she had all of them yeah and of
course the question that she asked that
every once and i was like what's up with
the name of your baby kylie right and i
think kyla gave such a reasonable
response she was like you don't
understand like they don't at the
hospital you have 10 days to sign the
birth certificate so you're rushed and
she has a couple names she doesn't know
what she's going to end up with but she
doesn't want to say it because she might
change her mind again yeah and all the
sisters were like it is the hardest
thing in the world that's what i've been
saying yeah it is that's what i've been
saying it's the hardest thing ever to
name a human being
and that's what they were saying and i'm
glad to know that like kylie still
doesn't have a name it's not that she's
withholding from us like right she still
hasn't decided because also now she's
bought herself some time like try out a
few different names this week maybe
it'll be haraldson right next week it
could be a little harry
yeah next week it could be valentine
like you know yeah
you never know i really appreciated the
the um candidness yeah the candicity
candicity and the ken descension also
true had her birthday and on the gift
bags it said baby webster so they're not
like hiding hiding anything from us and
they've been so open this week yes that
i really just don't feel like even when
allegedly kit
perhaps potentially we don't know who it
was
asked the question of like who's gonna
have like as much kids as chris like
courtney said that she wants two more
kim raised her thing which means that
she's gonna wants to have more kids like
we're just getting so much information
now back to the premiere something that
was bothering me about myself after the
episode that we did on thursday was like
we were like kylie was at the basketball
game but she wasn't on kimmel like
kylie's a new mom and like i just can't
believe i wasn't understanding that like
sometimes you can go to a basketball
game but you can also do kimmel
and that's with all this press stuff i
feel like she's at maybe like half of it
yeah but she has a new baby at home yeah
yeah like imagine you're promoting the
biggest show like this is a really like
the biggest thing that your family is
doing but like you've got haroldson at
home like she's doing as much as she can
of course of course of course you know
of course and i feel like i wasn't
sympathetic towards that when i'm
literally in the exact same position so
you're apologizing i'm apologizing yeah
i am apologizing to kylie because i know
she was listening yeah 100
um the premiere was everything of the
sort pete was there they did not walk
the carpet together but we did get a
bunch of pictures of them um holding
hands like backstage and then kim posted
yesterday because you know kim loves to
post like delayed she doesn't post in
real time um she posted like pictures of
them getting dinner afterwards two
pictures a carousel
both like
the same setup but just like different
faces um i was taking in every ounce of
this picture like first of all the diet
coke stunning like i was just
bereft
the plates like i think kim's plate had
a crust on it um there was also um it
looked like they were done eating but
there was like a full salad in the
middle that had a mid-touch which i just
thought was funny relatable yeah it's
like if you're at a pizza place like why
are you ordering a salad yeah no the
meal looked delicious she posted me on
her story like when she was there and it
just looked did she say what restaurant
was no but we gotta go i was like just
guessing i think it's john and vinnie's
but that's just me being like so yeah
okay yeah that i just want to say i
didn't even see that anywhere i was just
like doing um
guess guess work investigative work okay
well when ever the next time we're in la
is we have to go there we just read it
looked phenomenal so she posted pictures
of them like being lovey and cute and
like they're full steam ahead and like
now she's talking about him impressed
she's not even being coy he was at the
red carpet they didn't give us the photo
moment which was fine because like it
was cute to see them behind the scenes
like him just being really supportive um
she was asked by someone about the met
yes i was just going to say that and she
said something so interesting like
she'll go if the dress fits right like
the dress can't be all the dress can't
be altered so she won't know until like
a week before if she's able to go
because if she doesn't fit into the
dress she's not going there's no way
she's not going isn't she on the
committee this year i don't know and
also i saw yesterday that the theme this
year again is like america at legion
lexicon whatever right america's stiney
lexington yeah right right but with a
focus on the gilded age
so i'm actually really excited stunning
yeah stunning so who knows what kim's
going to wear but she better be there
and she better be with pete especially
since we've also recently learned that
the first time that they like sort of
connected was at the met gala this year
yeah so on the not skinny monopod
podcast she told the story of like
he basically was like they hadn't
announced that she was going to be on
snl yet like to the public but everyone
who works at snl new and they were
talking about at the met gala and he was
like well if you need like any help or
anything like take my number but she was
wearing you know that
outfit
that her hands were in gloves and she's
like oh sorry like i can't use my phone
right now because my fingers don't work
and he was like okay that's fine and
then walked away and she was like no
wait but like you take my phone number
and he didn't hear and just like they
never connected and they didn't even
really like connect at snl he didn't
come to the after party for her ever she
said literally everyone came even rami
malik who was hosting next week yeah
everyone came except for pete
um
and they didn't connect until later
right and we'll find out how they
connected on the show she wasn't ready
to share that with us plus there has to
be like something
that's like new information there's also
apparently like a lot that happens that
we don't know about like i remember when
kanye was like you know
posting a lot on social media he was
talking about like a sex tape a second
sex tape with ray j and that's
apparently what happens in the first
episode and that's burn them to the
ground yes
got it yes okay very exciting that the
show premieres on the 14th at midnight
though so like the 13th is that tonight
what's today's date
today's the 12th okay so tomorrow at
midnight oh my god i'll have to stay up
yeah i'm so excited yeah so
i think that's everything all of the new
information that they've shared with us
yes i think so too and all the press
that they've done and they went on a
double date with lauren sanchez and jeff
bezos and like it sounds random but
obviously there's a connection between
pete davidson and jeff bezos because he
was going to go on blue origin but last
minute i had to like change i think
scheduling conflict right so obviously
like they're friends
interesting i'm like not i don't know
why i'm like not here for it i wish it
was elon and grimes no i'm not here for
it at all like kim and pete to me like
are so interesting and you have to like
level up with your double dates like me
and ben would be perfect like just
perfect perfect perfect yeah so you're
saying that jeff bezos and lorna stepped
down for them yeah okay yeah
yeah i am saying that okay yeah i think
i said what i said everyone would agree
yeah
but that's cute that they're double
dating yeah and whatnot yeah i just feel
like
someone else
yeah i'm really looking forward to
seeing like this side of pete that like
clearly everyone sees and knows and
loves and we're not really privy to all
the time yeah another thing about the
premiere is that courtney walked blended
family style with only rain from her
family and then alabama landon and the
older one whose name i can't remember um
it was a blended moment very drew
barrymore adam sandler you love to see
it you do you do and then kim went on
not to even nothing podcasts i listened
this morning me too she's talking about
snl she's talking about kanye so she's
just so
mature and so
always oh like it's so admirable
i can't like and amanda was like
but like does that annoy you and she's
like no
you didn't yeah so honestly in so many
ways i don't relate to kim right but i'm
sure it's easy to be so mature and take
the high road when she's so happy yeah
you know and she'll do whatever she
needs to do to keep it cool over there
and she can enjoy this season of her
life that's true you know that's true
yeah i feel that um so that concludes
our kardashian segment you never know if
we're going to circle back to them you
never know all roads do lead back and
that's not our fault 100
hundred percent
hundred percent
next story a little more love news that
claudia and i are just like [ __ ]
quaking over nicola peltz married
brooklyn background
nicholas sorry i guess i'm not that
quake-y
like someone has to seriously take me to
the hospital the way i would take a
bullet for these two people and like and
they're just a week wedding ceremony i
know and a week ago like i couldn't like
i wasn't even clear on what was going on
obsessed to the nth degree here's why
i'm so okay so
you might know her as nicola ann peltz
on instagram right married brooklyn
beckham um in palm beach she's wearing
valentino she's giving claudia schiffer
claudia schiffer then reposted so
excited to be the inspo brooklyn beckham
obviously as you know is the
son son of victoria beckham and david
beckham and nicola is the daughter of
the billionaire um so raise your hand if
you followed nick lapels on instagram
this week oh i don't think i did yet but
i'm so close to it i've been to her page
now like four times so [ __ ] premium
looking for new pictures it's so premium
i watched your story like everything let
me tell you why i'm so obsessed with
this wedding first of all the fact that
she was my second search just follow her
it's pretty followed it's done um here's
why i'm obsessed first of all and i
didn't even know but the fact that
she had brooklyn back and back i'm
wearing a yarmulke because she's jewish
and they were married by a rabbi like
that just
makes my heart flutter
i never in my life saw someone so
[ __ ] beautiful in my life this dress
so simple but so complicated like the
gloves the hair and when she said
claudia schiffer was her hair
inspiration i saw it
everything was just top top top tier her
house it was at her house her father's
house 100 million house in palm beach
obsessed gotta get me one of those um
need more pictures like
i will die like i just need more
pictures so many celebs were there eva
longoria tommy hilfiger and that's the
most iconic part the wedding was just
like so filled with celebrities that
like the one picture they sold to vogue
is like the main photo for the exclusive
who's in the background tell me he'll
figure like that's just how that's how
elegant you see it there he is that's
just how elegant they are like there
were so many like famous rich people
they just couldn't help but get one in
the background you know yeah iconic so
iconic i so we like they've been around
for a while and they like are you know
very cute and very very into each other
publicly into each other but they're
like a little bit younger than us so we
we're not really dabbling and what's
interesting is that brooklyn beckham is
23. nichola peltz is 27. oh that is
interesting so just unique unique
factors things and he's just like so
much here but i feel like for me i found
it like a warm place for them when they
went to the mac gala last year and like
they looked aces yeah and i actually
feel like her met gala look like kind of
resembles her wedding look i feel like
she was like this suits me it was you
know like a classic uh silhouette and
gloves and they just like looked so
darling yeah
and there's just like
there's just something so like it about
this
she's an it girl this wedding was the it
of the century like and you might not
know her because her her instagram
buyers like actor director producer
love you dearly she's a stunner yeah
never heard of any of your work um
let me let me and she's imdb
she's like uh she is where she is
because she's the daughter of a
billionaire and you know what that
doesn't even bother me like get it get
more opportunities like i love it i love
you know i want to see her more like
clearly also do you remember because
this was always my like now my
association with her will be like this
it period but do you remember when like
bella thorne was like
talking about like cr she was
cryptically talking about like a mean
girl in hollywood
yes oh my god yes and it was
nicola pretty sure that's so funny that
that's your association association up
until this weekend here's
okay my association
was she used to date
ex-boyfriend hold on
i think she used to date
alex pettifer do you remember him yes
did they date
so many of my favorite movies yeah like
bad movies
did they ever date agree to disagree
maybe that doesn't ring a bell to me
that doesn't ring a bell
they were in a movie together so it's
like hard to find any
i thought that that's like my
association i don't know why no my
association was like this bella thorne
cryptic thing where she's no but i know
exactly what you're talking about a mean
girl in hollywood um
who's like bullying her and stuff and so
like i guess up until this weekend i
just had like kind of a negative
association but now i i don't i don't
think so no i just need more photos like
thank god to the daily mail for doing
the lord's work with like the blurry
drone footages they had three enormous
tents in her backyard like one for
ceremony one for reception maybe one for
after party or cocktail hour it was so
beautifully done like so elegant and
these pictures it's just insane she
looks like she's in like a grand country
club and it's literally her house
stunning i think also she might have
dated greg sulkin
stop because i'm googling it and like
they were in a movie together and i was
also just like having that association
and that would make sense by bella like
oh right
i don't know unique yeah yeah yeah yeah
we'll have desk lauren elizabeth yeah
yeah she'll know everything
um so i'm just obsessed with this like i
need more photos i cannot consume enough
content so happy for them and then the
victorian david of it all like just it's
too much like did you see like the next
morning
nicola and brooklyn and then david and
victoria like went to brunch in matching
blue convertibles like vintage
convertibles driving around palm beach
like the paparazzi pictures it was so
rich it's too much no it's too much and
they say we don't have royalty here this
is this very much feels like a royal
wedding honestly yeah and like how the
exclusive was with british vogue just
like very elevated very elegant not like
other weddings no there was something
incredibly special about it in addition
to the fact that it was a jewish wedding
oh i know but you just love to see and i
had myself wondering if i was like oh
yeah david beckham is jewish
i never i didn't think for one second it
was her oh and the most interesting
thing about all of this is like okay you
know
when we hear these two obviously we've
heard of brooklyn beckham i think a
little bit more than we've heard of
nikola peltz um and brooklyn beckham was
the one who had to sign a prenup because
she's and like his family's worth 500
million a measly 500 million her dad
nicola's dad is like so rich she had to
give him a prenup yeah and also he's
taking her last name they're the pelts
beckham's well okay that's interesting
yeah so his
victoria's captain okay so
nickelodeon yeah i know because it looks
like the perfect wedding but you know
what even rich people have crazy in-law
problems because
basically
everyone's been talking about how like
they're so modern they're so progressive
like he respects women because he is now
brooklyn peltz beckham she is nicola
peltz beckham and her instagram when she
announced the wedding was mr and mrs
peltz beckham so they're doing like a
hyphen middle name thing and everyone
has been referring to them as pelts
beckham belts beckham pals beckham then
victoria beckham posted on instagram
from the wedding and was like mr and mrs
beckham
so maybe she's like getting it
maybe one someone on her team it was the
only thing that like was a little bit
crack in the in the surface
yeah there's something something totally
and also just the cons when i also
everything is so misleading cause all
the headlines are like brooklyn's taking
her last name i'm like okay so he's
brooklyn peltz right he's not he's not
they're like combining which i actually
love because i feel like even in our
family we'll be like oh the ashrae
shapiro is like it's just it works you
can't do it forever because then
everyone would have like think of two
last names and four last names yeah so
it's like squared like
two four four sixteen thirty six yeah
yeah yeah
i know we do that too like the ashrae
shapiro's the ashrae software is 100
yeah
but um
and also like
this is maybe me just being like such an
independent female like i like don't
subscribe to the changing of names like
if i use when i like was younger i'm
gonna get married and i'm gonna be like
you know claudia rockefeller
and
now i'm like first of all logistically
there's no [ __ ] way i'm filling out
all that paperwork are you okay
this is so funny there's no way i'm
filling out all that paperwork and also
like it's my [ __ ] name like you're
kidding me i have to change my name
that's like
just asking a lot like i'm not doing it
no it's a lot and then just wait till
you are pregnant and birth a child and
it's like
what what i was like i did this so you
get this fucker's last name you're okay
right it's so it's so crazy and i agree
when i was like before i was in it i was
like yeah of course they changed
like someone who's like how sweet who's
so stubborn about that right but now
it's just like also for me like being
tracky oh right no and then we're gonna
marry someone last name oh you should
have yeah married your cousin then
then i'm not gonna necessarily change
right it's even harder when you're
building a brand it's even harder when
you're building brand look at kkw right
exactly and well that's just what we
need another rebrand right no it's
really like it's crazy i'm so here for
what they're doing yeah it's not for
everyone and as we've stated like
victoria obviously doesn't subscribe to
it either yeah but the here and now it's
really quite beautiful um so i'm so glad
we got to talk about this wedding
because obsessed doesn't even begin i'm
like scraping the bottom of the barrel
for content like
and like a couple people i follow on
instagram were there and i'm just like
send me pics
really yeah exciting so good
um so before we move on i just want to
let everyone know that today's episode
is brought to you by curology curology
is a game-changing custom skincare made
for you by a dermatology provider
they'll create custom prescription cream
for your specific goals whether that's
tackling acne clogged pores skin texture
dark spots fine lines or even something
else you'll start by taking a short
online quiz and uploading photos and if
it's a good fit they'll ship you your
formula right to your door it even has
your name on the bottle
there's really no reason why all of us
should be using the exact same same
skincare we all have such different
needs like for me i have really dry skin
especially in the winter a lot of people
struggle with fine lines or dark spots
so we should all be really using
different things that work best for our
skin and i found a lot of really um
really positive experiences with
curology i bring it with me on tour the
moisturizer is amazing um and i really
like taking the quiz because it was
teaching me things about my skin like i
didn't even know just like asking really
specific questions and then getting some
really up-close and frankly heinous
photos of my skin so they can really
like
make sure they're giving you the exact
right products that you need get started
with curology just like i did and a free
30-day trial at curology.com
toast just pay five dollars for shipping
and handling that's
o g c-u-r-o-l-o-g-y dot com toast to
start your free 30-day trial you can
cancel any time and your prescription is
subject to consultation check out
curology you won't regret it it's a
fabulous experience and your skin will
thank you
thank you claudia it's a pleasure
our next story britney spears is leaving
fans confused with an instagram post
about quote having a baby
so britney spears posted to instagram
letting us know that she was pregnant
question mark or is it a food baby we're
not sure she said i lost so much weight
to go on my maui trip only to gain it
back i thought geez what happened to my
stomach my husband said no your food
pregnant silly so i got a pregnancy test
and uh well i am having a baby
four days later i got a little more food
pregnant it's growing if two are in
there i might just lose it i obviously
won't be going out as much due to the
paps getting their money shots of me
like they unfortunately already have
it's hard because when i was pregnant i
had perinatal depression she also talks
about her experience with depression and
she's glad that more people are talking
about it now but here's the thing she
just said i'm pregnant with a baby
i'm having she said quote
no i don't think she's pregnant
but she said
uh well it sounds like a really bad joke
like about a food baby that she like
took the joke a little too far oh you
think so i don't think she's pregnant
she said i am having a baby quote
but what about the context around the
sentence no but like that was just like
the way to how she discovered she was
pregnant she was a little belly is it a
food then she said four days later she
had another food baby because she baby's
growing
um i don't i just wanna i don't i think
she's not pregnant
um
i'm just like she just told she's
pregnant where she told us she's having
a baby so like why don't we just believe
her no i know it's like ever when i was
looking for the stories it was like i
just searched britney spears everyone
was like fans are confused britney
leaves fans wondering when it sounds
like she was pretty clear but even me i
don't think she's pregnant yeah no i i
even though she said so this could be
confusing maybe it was a joke that she
got twisted i don't know yeah but her
instagram captions are just very
difficult to decipher yeah
yeah it's a hard way to keep up with her
she did also refer to sam as her husband
which was shocking with that new news
yeah they're engaged is that true even
sometimes like i feel like i'm calling
kylie and travis like we're calling each
other wife and husband i don't know i
call everyone like someone's husband
like once you've been dating for a long
time agreed agreed so i don't know i
don't know what to take from this i'm
still waiting for like the britney sit
down the britney book and it was
reported that brittany has started a
memoir um as predicted by me hopefully
it's less confusing than these captions
no i know like she i do believe like
every celebrity she'll need to work with
a writer because and make it jessica
simpson's ghostwriter yeah because
britney is a lot of things but she's not
really concise and the book will be 2000
pages unless she works with a writer
yeah with like a lot of emojis i was
gonna say
no emojis yeah so i
i don't think she's pregnant i just want
to go on the record and say okay but she
said that she's having a baby but it
could be a food baby no i don't you
don't either okay yeah no i don't i
don't know honestly
i mean like i'm not the britney expert i
feel like she's definitely having a lot
of sex mm-hmm she's going on all these
trips romantic trips she's free she's
celebrating she says that she has said
that she wants more kids yeah and she's
right but i don't know i'm still
literally just like still joking
it's right in front of us but still no
i'm not seeing it okay
are you ready for our fifth and final
story which is a story that is so dear
to my heart and i have a lot of thoughts
and claudia has a song that she's gonna
lead us into turn your volume down for
anyone with a sleeping baby which now i
am sympathetic i really am so let's give
them from i'm gonna move the microphone
away four
three
two
one it's the final story
please adopt me
and that's a magic number
okay our fifth and final story a little
exciting historical content news the
crown prequel is in the works at netflix
thank god because every time they like
they refuse to
prolong the show they're like nope this
is the final season final season even
though we're obsessed so thank god thank
god and i can't remember if i said it on
this show but i don't think that i did
otherwise like more people would be
tagging me in this but you know i'm
obsessed with the show victoria it's
only had three seasons oh and by the way
because i've been traveling so much this
month i have made so i'm on season two
now like i've made so much production
it's so good it's so good so it's been
three seasons and it's unclear if it's
coming back for season four i actually
like recently right and by the way i saw
on like a facebook comment on like a fan
page for the show victoria from just
like someone who said that they're
waiting longer for jenna coleman to age
get older right so that they don't have
to do too much makeup but like how much
is she going to age what are we going to
wait 10 years no i know and she's like
an actress in hollywood so she's
probably not loving this like being
forced to age when she wants to
preventatively just get the botox but
really like it was a rumor started by
like a fan in the british countryside so
like
don't don't take it but i thought it was
i thought he had a big base on the
situation anyways it's been three
seasons it doesn't feel like season four
is coming and i would actually said to
someone if whoever it was please show
yourself so i don't look like i'm making
this up i said that it should the cro
the crown show should absorb this and
make it the crown prequel well what year
is
is
victoria victoria starts in like the
1860s i know the 1840s and 50s and then
this show okay so this prequel is
speculated that it will kick off with
the death of queen victoria in 1901.
got it but like spoiler alert victoria
dies spoiler alert but like why not back
it up a little bit give us victoria
she's a literal queen and she's so
fascinating right legendary she's so
fascinating yeah you guys have to watch
victoria like if you take nothing else
away from the show watch victoria it's
really good i watch it too and if
claudia likes it yeah it took me like a
second to get into it i'm not gonna lie
um
but yeah it takes a second because
you're like this is a really long time
ago yeah right right you know and it's
like the thing with downton abbey that i
liked so much it was like really like
the turn of the century like
you know from the beginning to the end
like
so much had happened so many inventions
they got electricity like no it's really
about them like embracing modernity and
you can like see how much the world
changed in those 20 years roughly
more innovation and technological
exactly so like with victoria that
happens
to like the train oh the train gas
lighting the steam train yeah the train
oh my god don't you just love albert i
don't actually really yeah he's like
such
an innovator
he's actually you're you're gonna start
to hate him more and also like this is
gonna be really mean but like he's kind
of ugly like victoria is so much
prettier you know this idiot in real
life no the actresses the actors and
they like while they were filming they
were dating i just think the show makes
him look ugly like with his big
sideburns and his like hair it's just
not the vibe well i'm sure he's very
handsome in real life yeah but i also
think that
they had to like these are stunning
actors and i don't think the real people
were that wasn't as stunning but you
know what i don't mind them taking no
creativity i love a glamatization of
history yeah and it's really on the nose
of what happened yeah anyways keep
watching i will keep me updated on your
thoughts i will but crown people you
know what for fans of victoria then the
crown prequel will tackle a different
era and i'm here for that as well me too
i'm just happy we're getting more crown
content because the crown is literally
one of the best shows like ever made
um
and for some reason i mean i know i
understand why like they're reaching a
point in history that's kind of close to
current events yeah no and there would
just be like too many enemies there's
too many cooks in the kitchen opinions
who knows what happened history hasn't
been written yet right i think like
diana is really like the the last thing
we can consider like history yeah yeah i
agree they don't want to make enemies
with people who are living like i can
get that even though like the queen is
still alive but it is quite favorable
yeah so i'm i'm just grateful we're
getting more content because it's so
well done
it's i think very accurate and it's just
a gorgeous show so any
news that we're getting more content is
great news for me yeah i'm really
excited especially because like post
victoria like i'm familiar with how
things unravel after that but i can
never like fully remember it so this
will have it seared into my brain yeah i
love it um and i love you and i love the
toasters who are gonna unburden
themselves for us in the next segment so
unburden ourselves
is it and burden yourselves
yourself you really need to work on the
branding
it's yourselves so unburdening
yourselves is a segment we started here
where you guys can write in to unburden
yourselves at gmail.com if there's
something that's weighing on you like
something really embarrassing you did
over the weekend that you just want to
unburden do write in we have really good
ones today and it's brought to you by
solo stove
upgrade your backyard with a solo stove
fire pit it's the perfect catalyst for
getting outside and spending more time
with family and friends build lasting
memories around a solo stove fire pit
and that season is upon us you know
there's like a little chill in the air
it's the perfect time to get outside at
night you know light a little solar
stove roast a marshmallow cuddle with
with a blanket or a dog or a man or a
woman like just just get it done solo
stove is really that [ __ ] solo stove
fire pits are brilliantly engineered
they're made with premium grade 304
stainless steel and they have a 360
degree airflow system that maximizes
efficiency while minimizing smoke that's
like sometimes the worst part of
lighting a fire it's like oh you're just
sitting there like pretending to enjoy
it but your eyes are slowly dying um and
solo stove is engineered to help that
not happen
um it's easy to light with a few bits of
starter your fire is blazing in minutes
and it's perfectly portable take solo
stove with you i'm camping trips and
more so obviously we don't have like a
backyard but we have a solo stove every
time we go upstate or we rent a house
every time we go anywhere it's the first
thing in the car it's really such a
premium product so if you have a
backyard you're lucky enough
fabulous product for you but it's really
kind of a cost-efficient way of putting
in a fire pit in your backyard and even
if you live in an apartment and you like
to take trip slaughter you go camping
get a solo stove it's really premium
shop now and get up to 30 off fire pits
all month long and use the promo code
toast at checkout to get an extra 20 off
plus a lifetime warranty and a free
30-day return go to solostove.com and
remember you'll get 20 off when you use
promo code toast at solostove.com okay
you ready yes hey gorgeous girls hi my
toxic trait is that when whenever
there's a unisex bathroom in a public
space i feel compelled to have sex in it
so last weekend when i was at a
co-workers black tie wedding and learned
at the bathroom was unisex i immediately
knew i had to have sex while i was in
there i got pretty drunk which wasn't a
big deal because all the co-workers were
there and i told my fiance
that we should go to the bathroom okay
he says she has a fiance i thought she
was like you know like now you have to
find something right that's what i
thought too
he politely declined as any sane person
would in that moment and in my drunken
state i decided that i needed to do
something to entice him so while we were
at the table eating dinner i took out my
boob just one boob my co-worker next to
me quickly realized i had my tit out
exclaimed and helped me get back in my
dress honestly i'm not sure if that's
the worst part after dancing for a while
a group of us went outside to cool off i
again tried to get my fiance to come
with me in the bathroom and he again
declined my counteroffer this time was
that i would lick his balls when he
declined again i started asking all of
my male co-workers and the female
co-workers husbands if they'd rather sit
outside or get their balls licked
i could cry
when my fiance and i were recapping this
the next day he reminded me that i took
out the boob with the pierced nipple to
which i replied well why would i take
out the nipple that isn't pierced his
logical response why would you take out
either of your boobs i think i need to
stop drinking with my co-workers ella
well you know what i kind of agreed like
this story is funny and it's only like
kind of bad because you're with people
you work with yes so i just think like
you sound like a great time you do gotta
party with you you do but you could take
it down one or two notches i mean asking
your female co-workers husbands if
they'd rather sit outside or get their
balls that to me that's where she really
crosses the line right other people's
husbands assuming you're at a table
there's other males there and you have
your breasts out like that would also
bother me but like to be the girl who's
like you know
it's a little pick me to be like would
you rather yeah yeah no i'd rather sit
outside no you have to stop drinking
with your coworkers absolutely but i
kind of want to know what your fiance's
take was on all this because it sounds
like he was like thinking it was funny
and like that makes me love him that
he's not like right but it sounds like
it's just another day with you right now
you sound awesome you do sound awesome
and i don't want to kill your spirit
whatsoever but the co-workers is what
makes it a problem yeah but you know
what what you do outside the office it
doesn't matter the thing is then you
have to answer for it inside the office
and then people are looking at you and
and you spend so much time at work
you try not to make your time at work
like more
difficult than it needs to be but it
sounds like you're not someone who's
concerned with what other people think
you are like a walking hr violation but
i love that but it was outside the
office right it doesn't count it doesn't
count i don't know
i don't think i don't think so
i don't think it does that would be
weird if like hr was monitoring what you
do in the real world like that would be
like
a big dictatorship yeah yeah yeah so i
use like
it's if if it's not bothering you the
only thing i would like sort of
reprimand you for is like the co-worker
element
yes agree like do this with your friends
from college you know yeah but it sounds
like i mean maybe the co-workers you
just have this like good drinking
culture or something but right in
general it's like certain like work
cultures outside of like the workplace
people who are like really close and
they get really wasted it can be really
toxic yeah no
my advice to anyone in general i think
it's just like good advice is just like
not to really get drunk at work
eventually around work people but that's
also because like i'm a deeply awkward
person and any like i can barely like
answer for myself yeah in a corporate
situation let alone drunk me yeah i
can't answer for her yeah oh my god i
would have to i would leave yeah i miss
her
yeah no
miss her daughter she'll be back but not
in any sort of corporate environment of
course i mean do you often hang out in
corporate environments no no not anymore
but if and when i when yeah you know
like a holiday party two drink maximum i
agree
on your shoulder agree you will thank me
all right next up ladies i'm currently
visiting my husband's extended family
for his cousin's wedding and i met a lot
of his relatives for their first time
here today we spent the day with his
cousins she's writing dave yeah she's
desperate
we spent the day with his cousins aunts
uncles and i was so happy with how
everything went until i was changing out
of my dress
at the end of the night and i saw a
large period stain on my dress it was
light spotting and i was wearing dark
underwear so i didn't notice when i went
to the bathroom earlier in the day but
my white and blue gingham dress showed
every little mark i immediately asked my
husband and he said yeah i saw it
earlier but thought it wasn't a big deal
and there was nothing you could do about
it so it wasn't worth telling you and
making you anxious about it for the rest
of the day he also said all his cousins
are guys and wouldn't know what it was
are you [ __ ] kidding me i of course
let him know this was such a [ __ ]
[ __ ] move and to immediately tell me
the second he saw something next time i
know this is silly but is there anything
more humiliating than a period stain it
was so obvious and there's no way it
went on notice the entire trip has now
been stained with this incident i'm now
that girl that got her period on her
dress i want to evacuate the country
before i even go to the wedding this
weekend fml i want to say i do think
your husband's heart was in the right
place but like boys are just morons
you could have tied something around
your waist but you could have went to
the bathroom gotten the stain out and
then like put toilet paper in your
underwear like there was a million
things you could have done a million
things you could do but i do think like
this is him not being an [ __ ] just
being like so dumb like of course but
with the with the purest of hearts of
course but you have to live with the
fact that like you thought you were
making this amazing impression on
everyone and it's like the whole time
you had food in your teeth you know 100
but i want to give you an alternate
perspective to think of this is your
boyfriend she was meeting a family for
the first time right so look at you you
are just you have your period like
you're so fertile right right ready you
were showing off
[Music]
[Laughter]
you're ready to have this man's children
to bring grandchildren nieces nephew
generations
and i think
if they if they have any respect for
symbolism right right that's what they
will have
yeah okay i also do want to say it's
entirely possible like people didn't see
it because if there was like a girl aunt
or a girl cousin a girl would have
pulled you over and be like [ __ ] you
got your period here's the tampon i'll
come through the bathroom like most
girls if i saw someone like at a family
thing that had that i would pull them
over and be like come i have a tampon
yeah a stranger
no let's say um
okay i need to think of like a really
random like
instance okay let's say i'm at a family
thing
with ben's family okay
and ben's
ben's sister has a boyfriend great guy
max and max's sister came i'm just like
coming up with like yeah because we
don't have a sister right has a brother
right so so max's sister came and she
was wearing like a cute dress and she
had like a stain and like i knew what it
was i would totally i'm like a woman who
supports other women i would totally be
like come to the bathroom let's find you
a tampon
i would totally do that
or you know what i would actually do
sorry i would tell maddie ben's sister
max's sister my son doesn't even have a
sister okay but that's what i would do
okay yes i would send someone over there
like it's impossible someone would have
come over if it was really that big
everybody saw it then there would have
been one person in there who it's in
their character to tell you personally i
don't think it could be me like if i saw
it i would reprogram my mind to pretend
that i didn't see it and just move on
you know no i would find a way to get
the girl help but like probably
indirectly if i'm being honest it would
have to be like really really bad like
gushing yeah in which case you're
showing off
okay also one more thing is i think it's
also really important with a lot of
these unburden yourselves
i think it's important to remember
that
you will find a lot of peace
and a lot of relief when you realize
like
nobody cares about you like people are
so involved in their own bullshittery
like their own lives i'm always thinking
like what are people thinking oh did did
i act weird it's like no one cares about
you [ __ ] like people really care about
themselves i agree
like 99.9 percent of the time but the
instances that we've had today i'm sorry
like the boob at the table like oh no i
was talking
i'm talking about that the next day so
for me i'm like me and my fall like
right i definitely fell and people
definitely stopped but i don't think
people think about it to this day in the
way that i do no not at all but i think
when you take your boob out at a wedding
people think about it to this day yeah
it's like part of the canon
um
now i don't think people are going to be
talking about like the period same oh so
it depends on the size i could have a
photo would have been helpful but also
was it a barbecue like maybe it was
ketchup you know like what was the
outing it was she was wearing gingham so
it could have been a barbecue it was was
before a wedding so like uh it totally
could have been a barbecue yeah or like
an event where they serve ketchup or
barbecue sauce hot sauce
it's an option
okay our third and final one is i met
this girl
i'm not going to blow up her spot but i
met her and she was like i wrote in 10
burden yourself i'm like oh what was it
and it was the most disgusting thing
like i've ever heard and i was like okay
i'm going to go into the email and find
it we found it and we are going to read
it great hello claudia and jackie hello
first let me say i love you both so much
listening to your podcast has given me a
lot of joy in life thank you so much for
all you do i am ready to unburden myself
from a night that i don't quite regret
but i very much need to heir to the
world
basically on a cool spring night in
downtown manhattan i found myself
through one course of action and another
extremely drunk with two of my
girlfriends in the subway as we were
chatting waiting for the train one of my
friends flailed her arm and hit mine
which sent my phone that i was holding
soaring into the subway tracks commotion
ensued we were running around like crazy
women trying to come up with the best
solution the phone was not on the tracks
but rather off to the sides so trains
wouldn't go by leaving it unscathed
in the commotion of the running
in the commotion of running to the train
engineers booth at 2am multiple random
people saying they would go down and get
it for 100 bucks and one of my best
friends offered to hop down on the
tracks and get it a random man dare i
say my hero hopped down to the tracks
grabbed my phone and was back up on the
platform in seconds we were in shock and
awe
especially me i guess who after
realizing i had no cash and nothing to
repay him with and learning he was a
student at nyu i asked are you a
heterosexual man to which she replied
yes i then asked him if he wanted to
make out and with this with his full
consent we shared a hot and heavy
makeout session on the not so empty
subway platform i then broke away
grabbed my beautiful story why i wasn't
in the new york post i then broke away
grabbed my friends and we ran out to the
station without saying a word to this
man i sometimes wonder who saw this make
out and where this man is now he was a
random nyu student so if you're out
there thanks again for getting my phone
i hope you enjoyed the makeout as much
as i did sincerely a slightly
embarrassed yet unashamed toaster this
is like so adorable i know like that guy
like people were offering to do it for a
hundred dollars and she like didn't want
him for a kiss he did it for free no and
then she offered the kiss yeah i imagine
like she said it wasn't crowded on she
said it was crowded on the platform like
everyone probably saw like the ordeal
with the phone and like who's gonna get
it and they see this hero come through
and then there's a kiss at the end like
i would have been clapping what a show i
just have to say one thing kissing
someone who after they went down into
the subway tracks kissing on the subway
should be illegal it is the most vile
place on the planet it is never been
cleaned in its entirety
especially the traffic like if you look
at the tracks you'll see right
of rats it's crazy everything it's like
so normal they're so disgusting so i
just think like
kissing
any sort of like swabbing of fluids on
the train should be punishable by jail
like it's so disgusting yeah um but i
love this for you i love that you're not
ashamed of it i love that you found out
he was age-appropriate and got his
consent
so all in all sounds like a successful
evening on the subway like so cute i
hope they make a movie but in the movie
like then you guys obviously run home
and shower off into the sunset
but if anybody like you know knows who
this person is obviously he's not
watching but you know if his sister's
watching um and she's like oh my brother
is an miu student and he did help a girl
on the subway and got a kiss right
please connect these two yeah she lives
in chicago now i think i saw her in
chicago okay but i don't want to blow up
or spot any further any further
you know but i'm like giving a lot of
research
no this is like imagine being like the
kind of girl that could like inspire men
to just jump into the subway tracks to
get your phone couldn't be me
she sounds wonderful she she really was
like in everything in the store girly
yeah that's what it happens to like
certain types of people and she listens
to the toast so she's obviously like a
you know a special breed of human yeah
just like with someone that has that
energy it's like
you know people who like all the
craziest things happen to you that was a
great segment and i want to thank
everyone who wrote in to unburden
yourselves finally we did a whole
segment without talking about poop which
oh i also met small rocks poo girl
and how were those small rocks very poo
like
and how was she doing did she feel
lighter um she was just like she thought
the whole thing was so funny i mean it
was so funny it's like one of our
favorites yeah so thank you and your
small rocks poo thank you to everyone
who wrote in again the email is
unburdened yourselves we also had to
bring it back to poop just one week of
course
we got out and burden yourselves
gmail.com is the email tomorrow we are
back with
heather mcdonald remotely which i'm just
so excited like
nary is there a human i love more
and then thursday we're back in studio
with joey comasta also
so looking forward to it he's unhinged
and i just love him for that and then
friday we're back remote
with lauren elizabeth who is
a sister a friend
a hero a toaster and there's nothing
better so we just have like a sickening
week thank you for coming in i know how
hard it is i know you have a doctor's
appointment you have to get to so thank
you jackie thank you claudia thank you
haraldson
thank you claudia sinn thank you
toasters hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you so much for listening to
the morning shows the millennial morning
show where we deliver the fast five
stories that you need to know every
monday through friday on youtube so if
you're watching this on youtube please
feel free to subscribe and give this
video a thumbs up we're also available
as a podcast anywhere podcast can be
found so it's spotify itunes stitch or
public radio i have rated cast box all
the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us morning toast leave a 5
star review about how beautiful stunning
and smart we are hope you guys have an
amazing tuesday and we'll see you
tomorrow for hump day
goodbye
you